before this important speech joe biden
took time to pay tribute to a civil
rights icon he stopped at martin luther
king's graveside a man who fought for
rights the president now believes are at
risk
since the election that carried him to
the white house 19 states have changed
the rules about voting an attack on the
people says joe biden an attack on
democracy for the right to vote
and have that vote counted
is democracy's threshold liberty
without it
nothing is possible
but with it anything is possible
but while the denial of fair and free
elections is undemocratic
it is not
unprecedented
he made the speech in georgia one of the
places where the laws have changed it
cut the number of drop boxes made it
harder to ask for a mail-in vote even
made it illegal to hand water to people
waiting in line to vote
joe biden wants to change the rules in
the senate to push legislation through
against republican opposition but he
knows two senators from his own party
are dead set against that idea he threw
down this challenge
will you stand against voter suppression
yes or no that's the question they'll
answer
will you stand the leg against election
subversion
yes or no
will you stand for democracy yes or no
there's one thing every senator every
american should remember
history has never been kind to those
who've sided with voter suppression over
voters rights joe biden wrote to
election victory with the overwhelming
support of black voters and many experts
believe that's who would be most
disadvantaged by the change in the
legislation advocates who support a
national law didn't attend
they believe joe biden should be in
washington getting things done
not here talking about getting things
done
this is your party mr president these
are your soldiers you need to find a way
to get them in line because we delivered
for you to lead this party and now you
need to lead this party so help me god
congratulations mr president
[Applause]
joe biden like every president had an
ambitious agenda when he took office he
hasn't spent a lot of time on voting
rights this speech signals it's now a
priority supporters have heard the words
now they want results alan fisher al
jazeera atlanta georgia